this is our thread sterner sorry and
calm and in this video I'm going to
demonstrate how to give an intramuscular
injection in the deltoid before ever
administering any type of medication
including ayam injections you always
want to review your facility's protocol
and how they require you to administer
that certain medication now before
actually giving the ayam injection
there's some prep work you have to do
first of all you have to make sure you
have the right patient the right
medication are you giving the right dose
at the right time and the right route so
double-check all those things in
addition you want to get your supplies
ready and to do this you have to do some
critical thinking so first of all you
need to ask yourself ok what muscle are
we going to be giving this injection in
here in this video we're going to be
doing the deltoid so let's review some
things about the deltoid muscle it's
located up here in this region and this
muscles a little bit smaller than the
other muscles you can use it can only
hold about one to two milliliters of a
solution so if you need to give more
amounts of a solution you need to go in
a larger muscle like the ventral gluteal
muscle next you want to look at how your
patient is built generally the
guidelines for a needle length in giving
a deltoid injection is about a one-inch
needle to a one and a half inch needle
so look at your patient do they have a
lot of adipose fatty tissue over that
deltoid muscle if so you want to use the
longer of the two options so one and a
half needle length would be good here
we're going to use a one inch needle
next you want to look at the gauge of
needle this is how big that hole of that
needle is that allows that solution to
go through so most vaccines are watery
so you can give anywhere from a 20 to a
25 gauge needle here we're gonna use a
23 gauge but if you were doing like a
thicker solution that's all you would
want to use anywhere between an 18 to 25
gauge needle no what we're gonna do is
we're going to gather supplies perform
hand hygiene and it's optional if you
want to wear gloves
according to the CDC gov gloves are not
required when administering vaccines
unless the person administering the
Sene is likely to come into contact with
potentially infectious body fluids or
has openly jhin's on hands
therefore gloves are optional personally
I like to wear gloves because I never
know what I may come into contact with
then of course you want to explain the
procedure to the patient what you're
going to be doing what you're
administering to them in a tip whenever
I give vaccines I always like to ask the
patient
are they right or left-handed because I
like to give the deltoid I am injection
and their non-dominant arm because if
you've ever had a vaccine or an
injection before in your arm it can get
sore so always try to take that into
consideration before you give the
injection you can have the patient stand
or sit if your patient doesn't like
needles it's probably best to have them
sit in case they pass out so where we're
going is the deltoid muscle it's located
up in this area so what you want to do
is you want to have the patient
completely like relax their arm you do
not want this muscle to be tensed up
because it's going to be a little bit
more painful for them so tell them to
relax as much as possible then we're
going to find where we're going so to
find the deltoid muscle and for an
injection site we want to use landmarks
so our first landmark is called the pro
Mian process this is found high up where
the shoulder is and it comes out it's
like a bony prominence just fill in
yourself where it is it's really easy to
find so you're gonna feel that and
you're going to go about two fingers
width down from that area so we have our
two fingers so we're going to go about
right here in this area once we have our
area what we want to do is we want to
clean the injection site so we're going
to take our alcohol prep we're going to
start in the center and we're gonna work
our way outward and cleanse the area and
let that dry completely don't blow on it
let it air dry now to give the injection
what we're gonna do is we're gonna use
what's called a z track technique this
is now recommended for all I am
injections and what this technique does
is number one it decreases pain for the
patient but it helps prevent the
solution that we're instilling
from actually going in that sub cute
issue we want this to go in the muscle
not the sub-q tissue so the z track
technique helps with that back in the
day they taught to pinch the skin up
bunch it up to give the vaccine that's
no longer recommended but the Z track
method so what we're going to do to do
that we're going to take our
non-dominant hand and we're just going
to go to the side of where an injection
site is going to be and we're just going
to put a little bit of pressure and
we're just going to pull the skin to the
side then we're going to take our
dominant hand with injection the needle
and we're going to go in like we're
shooting a dart at a 90 degree angle and
you'll want to do this quickly to cause
the patient less pain so we want to
steady our syringe so we're going to
take our thumb and our forefinger and
just hold it steady
then we're gonna take our dominant hand
and depress the plunger and instill that
fluid slowly about over 10 seconds per
ml this was half an ml so we're gonna do
about five seconds and then once you
have instilled it wait about ten more
seconds to let all that fluid go down
into that muscle and then what we're
gonna do is we are going to take it out
the same angle we had inserted it we're
going to engage our safety never recap a
used needle then you can take a gauze
and cover the area sometimes it can
bleed if your patients on blood thinners
but never massage the area because that
can increase the solution going into the
sub-q tissue and then dispose of your
syringe a needle in the sharps container
once you're done with that of course
what you want to do is you want to
perform hand hygiene and you want to
document you're going to document what
muscle you use on what side and how the
patient responded along with how much
medication you instilled in that muscle
now notice whenever I was giving that I
am injection I did not aspirate
aspiration for ayam injections is no
longer recommended a core
to CDC gov they say aspiration before
injection of vaccines or toxoids which
is pulling back on the syringe plunger
after needle insertion before injection
is not necessary because no large
vessels are present at the recommended
injection sites and a process that
includes aspiration might be more
painful for infants okay so that wraps
up how to give an iamb injection in the
deltoid thank you so much for watching
and don't forget to subscribe to our
channel for more videos